hi welcome back to the show let's take a
look at the solution here so our load
asset function should first check the G
cash taxes dictionary for the file name
that was provided if the file is not
present in the cache then the result of
this access will return null if this
happens we know that the image hasn't
been loaded and we need to actually
issue a load call from here we can
actually create our image do our onload
and set our source once this is all done
we actually set the image object as the
value to the key of asset name inside of
the cash this allows us later once again
to go through query for a name and get
an object which you can see down here if
the object has already been loaded then
when we query for it will get us
something back which allows us to pass
that image object to the callback
function that was given to us